okay also heute fangen wir an mit einem
kurzen Rückblick dann letzte Sitzung da
ging es um die Frage was ist eine
individuelle Person das ist ein
spannendes Thema weil es natürlich auch
mit der praktischen Philosophie
zusammenhängt bevor wir überhaupt
behandeln können was eine Handlung ist
was Motivation ist müssen wir uns
eigentlich fragen wer hatte denn wer ist
motiviert ja wer hat Intentionalität und
wie die ganzen Dinge alle heißen und
deswegen möchte ich jetzt hier mit ihnen
noch ein bisschen Rückblick machen also
wir haben gesagt es gibt ganz
verschiedene Möglichkeiten Personen zu
bestimmen jetzt erstmal individuelle
Personen die Frage ist ja was ist ein
individuelle Person wir kommen heute auf
die Frage was ist eine kollektive Person
sind Sie diesen hier alle sitzen im
Vorlesungsraum sind sie eine kollektive
Person darüber werden wir diskutieren
aber jetzt geht es nochmal zu den
individuellen Personen also zu den nicht
weiter zusammengesetzten Personen sowie
jeder von ihnen eine ist man kann auch
sagen natürliche Personen
und am prominentes kann man schon sagen
ist die selbstbewusstseinstheorie von
John Lock John Lock hatte ich Ihnen
gesagt John Lock waren Philosoph wir
sehen auch gleich noch ein Bild aus dem
18 Jahrhundert und er hat gesagt wir
müssen zwischen drei Arten von
Identitäten unterscheiden also Identität
der Substanz Identität des Menschen und
davon noch verschiedene Identität der
Person viele würden sagen Identität des
Menschen Identität der Person da sollten
wir gar nicht dazwischen unterscheiden
jeder Mensch ist eine Person wenn ich
Mensch bin bin ich Personen aber es
könnte auch sein dass es nicht
menschliche Person gibt deshalb jetzt
mal dahingestellt aber Mensch sein ist
hinreichend für Person sein und schon
gesagt nein wenn wir den Menschen
bestimmen haben wir noch nicht wirklich
bestimmt was eine Person aus und er
schaut hier auf das was unsere Identität
ausmacht also das was uns zu uns macht
das wodurch wir mit uns identisch sind
was wir von uns wegnehmen können ohne
unsere Identität zu ändern dass ist eben
nicht entscheidend für Identität und
jetzt hat er hier zum Beispiel die
Identität der Substanz und da stellt er
sich zum Beispiel ein Stein vor stellen
sich mal einen Stein vor und jetzt
nehmen Sie von diesem Stein also mein
Buntsandstein ein schöner Stein den sie
dazu finden dann nehmen Sie jetzt ein
kleines Stückchen weg und jetzt kann man
sich fragen ist es noch derselbe Stein
und viele würden sagen ja natürlich das
sieht doch noch genauso aus dass ein
kleines Eckchen weg aber ist doch im
Grunde genommen derselben Stein und John
Lock sagt nein wenn ich nur ein noch so
kleines Teilchen wegnehme von einer
Substanz also substanze zum Beispiel ein
Stein man kann darüber diskutieren ob
das ja auch eine Substanz ist ist auch
eine Substanz wir kommen auch noch näher
drauf fassen Substanz ist
den könnte man allgemein sagen das
natürlich eine keine natürliche Substanz
ist ein Artefakt also ein künstlich
hergestelltes Ding was irgendwo ich weiß
nicht wo wo es hergestellt keine Ahnung
wenn sich denken ja Stein ist nicht
hergestellt zumindest nicht von etwas
was ein Ziel verfolgt hatte seitdem man
nimmt natürlich ein Schöpfer an ne aber
Steine sind eigentlich ziemlich
zufällige Produkte die können wir
natürlich erklären durch Erdgeschichte
aber die sind eigentlich kein wirklich
stabiler zusammenstein bei Kristallen
ist dann schon wieder ein bisschen
anders Kristalle haben wir dann ganz
interessantes Organisationsprinzip die
brechen auch nicht beliebig ab sondern
die brechen an Bruchkanten so wie es
eben die physikalische Struktur vorgibt
aber noch sagt wenn wir von so einem
Substanz die kein lebendiges Ding ist
also Steine vielleicht auch
Fernbedienung so ein kleines Ding
wegnehmen dann ist es nicht mehr
dasselbe sagt schon lange bei Menschen
im gegen ist es anders wir könnten
Menschen auch wenn man das nicht machen
sollte den kleinen Finger abschneiden
oder sollen mal den Fingernagel bisschen
abschneiden das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen menschlicher und der Mensch ist
trotzdem noch derselbe also für den
Stein und für den Menschen gelten
unterschiedliche identitätsbedingungen
der Mensch der hält es aus seine
Identität ist so stabil das kleine oder
vielleicht auch größte Änderung an seine
Identität nichts ausmachen können ja wir
hatten da Gedankenexperimente die sind
ein bisschen futuristisch dass man
Menschen erstmal die Beine ersetzt durch
Prothesen und dann die Arme durch
siliziumstrukturen und viele sagen das
ist immer noch derselbe Mensch warum
weil es eben ein organisch verfasstes
Wesen immer noch ist ihr könnt jetzt
aber nicht beliebig weitergehen so sah
schon Log aus und wir müssen jetzt
schauen was die Person ausmacht was sie
von Menschen unterscheidet und also
erstmals ein denkendes verständliches
Wesen das Vernunft und Überlegung
besitzt und sich selbst betrachten kann
das ist noch ein bisschen unspezifisch
wir hatten dann gesehen es ist noch ein
bisschen interessante er geht auf das
Bewusstsein ein also soweit dieses
Bewusstsein der Person sich auch
vergangene Gedanken richtet ausgedehnt
werden kann soweit reicht die Identität
Person das hat erstmal was sehr
plausibles weil dann bin ich ja auch
verantwortlich dafür wenn ich mich daran
erinnern kann dass ich es war dann kann
ich es mir selbst zuschreiben überlegen
Sie meine Situation wo man ihn sagt du
hast gestern in diesem Restaurant die
ganzen Biergläser auf dem Boden
geschmissen und sie waren am Ende kaputt
du hast einen Schaden angerichtet von
300 Euro und dann sagen Sie daran kann
ich mich aber gar nicht erinnern dass
das kann ich sagen das kann nicht sein
so da gibt es ein Problem also sie haben
die Intuition erst wenn ich mich an was
erinnern kann kann ich auch dafür zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden und das ist
so die Grund
Idee von John Lock also Erinnerung hat
was die Zuschreibung zu tun ja mit
Verantwortlichkeit natürlich auch dann
haben wir dieses bekannte Beispiel
diskutiert nehmen sie an die Seele eines
Fürsten sie können das beliebig anders
sich vorstellen hier ist der Witz dass
der Fürst natürlich sozialhöhe gestellt
ist als der des Schoß als der Schuster
also die Seele eines Fürsten oder
überlegen Sie das Bewusstsein eines
fürstens die mentalen Gehalt eines
Fürsten die treten ein in den lebendigen
Körper eines Schusters ob das geht ist
eine spannende Frage aber es ist ein
Gedankenexperiment nehmen wir mal davon
gehen wir mal an das geht wenn jetzt
also das Bewusstsein des Fürsten er sagt
jetzt die Seele in den belebten Körper
als Schusters eintritt dann wäre
praktisch der Schuster Körper der
belebte schusterkörper mit diesem
Bewusstsein für die Taten
verantwortlich die der Fürst begangen
hat weil das Bewusstsein das
entscheidende krit ist nicht der Körper
als Bewusstsein ist das worauf es
ankommt sagt John Lock und nicht der
beliebte Körper
genauso er geht noch ein Stückchen
weiter und sagt wir können dir soweit
aussehen oder so weit ausreizen dieses
Gedankenexperiment nehmen Sie an Ihr
Bewusstsein das Bewusstsein würde mit
ihrem kleinen Finger gehen das würde
ihren kleinen Finger reingehen und weg
von ihrem Gehirn oder ich weiß nicht wo
es sonst noch sein könnte dann wäre
praktisch die Person in dem kleinen
Finger also dahin wo das Bewusstsein
geht da wo der Erinnerung ist da ist die
Person selbst im kleinen Fingern es ist
ziemlich ja ziemlich provokativ was da
schon Lock gesagt hat das hat natürlich
auch viele Kritiker auf den Plan gerufen
Eric the Olsen ein bekannter Philosoph
einen Buch geschrieben the human animal
wenn Sie sich jetzt mal dieses Cover
anschauen ist mir jetzt erst kürzlich
aufgefallen was ist denn der Witz an
diesem Cover wenn sich Untertitel mal
lesen Personal identity without sigology
dann sehen sie dem Person fehlt der Kopf
da fehlt mir fehlt eigentlich auch noch
genau genommen die Arme fehlen auch noch
die aber hier fehlt der Kopf also das
ist der Witz er sagt durch human animal
das was uns ausmacht unsere
identitäts entspricht immer nur von uns
aber selfs er sagt nicht Menschen oder
Personen er lässt es völlig
dahingestellt er sagt uns was macht uns
aus und hier sagte was uns ausmacht ist
der beliebte Körper und die Psychologie
die man ja gemeinhin den Kopf ansetzt
die ist hier eben nicht zu entscheiden
wie weit schon Lock also er möchte jetzt
gerade sagen das was unsere Identität
ausmacht das hat nichts mit
Selbstbewusstsein zu tun und
Selbstbewusstsein wird häufig in der
Tradition von John Locke als
psychologische Eigenschaften gefasst
okay er hat jetzt hier ein paar Zitate
die können wir ein bisschen überspringen
worauf es mir ankommt ist dass er sagt
er vertritt die Person des animalismus
also wir sind Tiere menschliche Tiere
wir sind vielleicht phasenweise Personen
aber im Grunde genommen weil wir auch
mal phasenweise keine Person sein können
wenn wir schlafen oder als wir kleine
Kinder waren oder wenn wir vielleicht
mal noch älter werden und nicht mehr
ganz im vollbesitzer geistigen Kräfte
sind wir vielleicht auch keine Person
nach erigion was wir aber immer sind
unser ganzes Leben lang sofern wir leben
sind Menschen deswegen ist das
menschheitsprinzip oder der belebte
Organismus kann man genauer sagen
dasjenige was uns unsere Identität
verleiht als Menschen und nicht unser
Selbstbewusstsein weil das einfach nicht
stabil genug ist es gibt
selbstbewusstseinslücken wenn sie
schlafen wenn sie meinen Blackout haben
und so weiter und so fort würden sie
doch dennoch sagen ich existiere
weiterhin oder würden Sie sagen solange
ich schlafe und kein be ein bisschen
davon habe habe ich nicht existiert das
wären mitunter die Konsequenzen der
lokschen Theorie und every Olsen ist
also ein ganz scharfer Gegner von John
locks
Identitätstheorie der Person jetzt gibt
es ja eine neue Theorie Lyn Rider Baker
eine konstitutionstheorie wir müssen da
genau gar nicht näher eingehen was das
ist ich will nur auf einiges hinweisen
was Sie gegen den animalismus ein
gemäß dem animalismus von Eric Olsen
gibt es keine Unterscheidung zwischen
uns also in allen und mir und
Regenwürmer earthworms
und sie sagt das ist aber ziemlich
kontraktiv ja also wir haben doch andere
identitätsprinzipien als ein Regenwurm
würde sagen nein ein Regenbogen ist ein
belebte Organismus ein lebendiger
Organismus Stoffwechsel und so weiter
und so Fortpflanzung und so weiter und
das sind wir im Grunde genommen auch wir
sind komplexe Organismen vielleicht ein
bisschen komplexer als ein Regenwurm
aber im Grunde genommen sind wir
Organismus also sind wir jetzt sowas
oder sind wir sogar sowas ja das kann
man sich wirklich fragen ob wir wirklich
regenwürger Würmer sind für die die es
nicht wissen dass es Heidi Klum vor ein
paar Tagen mit ihrem Garten der sie an
der Angel hat
ja also sind wir nur Regenwürmer oder
gibt es sogar personale Regenwürmer wie
dieses Bild suggeriert wir haben darüber
diskutiert und wir sind zu folgendem
Ergebnis gekommen sind wir hier oder
Personen ich fand es faszinierend weil
es am ersten sehr viele von ihnen
mitgemacht ein 60 und es war eine ganz
ganz knappe Entscheidung also wenn sie
sehen ich vermute da ist nur ein zwei
stimmenunterschied das kann man jetzt
mal ausrechnen ja also ganz knapp die
ganz knappe Mehrheit von ihnen hat
gesagt wir sind wesentlich und das was
uns ausmacht ist die Person und nicht
ein Tier ja aber eine ganz knappe Sache
davon hängt jetzt gar nichts ab sie
wissen und hat lange Zeit gedacht dass
ich die Sonne um die Erde dreht zu einer
bestimmten Zeit da hätte man 99 Prozent
bekommen also umfragen sagen erstmal gar
nichts aus ich fand es nur interessant
ich habe einen anderen Seminar auch
dieselbe Umfrage gemacht und auch da war
es ungefähr 50 50 und
finde ich interessante ja interessante
Statistik ich werde es weiterhin
probieren in anderen Seminaren aber ich
glaube es wird ähnlich sein also wir
haben irgendwie total ausgeglichene
Intuitionen dafür dass wir Personen sind
oder auch Menschen ich habe kürzlich
eine Habilitationsschrift veröffentlicht
und ich habe eigentlich versucht diese
Intuition aufzunehmen und versucht wir
sind irgendwie beides kann man natürlich
nicht so leicht machen aber ich habe es
mal versucht weil irgendwie bei den
Traditionen ziemlich stark sind ja so
das war jetzt noch mal der Rückblick zur
letzten Sitzung und jetzt knüpfen wir da
nahtlos dran an heute geht es nämlich
jetzt um die Frage was ist eine
kollektive Person das ist natürlich auch
eine ganz ganz spannende Frage was eine
kollektive Person ist sie können schon
mal vom Titel her sich anschauen
Kollektiv heißt eine irgendwie Person
die aus verschiedenen
Individuen besteht also worin besteht
die Identität von kollektiven Personen
gibt sogar überhaupt also wenn sie gibt
wie existieren sie da muss ich gleich
sagen riesendebatte Obst Kollektiv
Person gibt manche sprechen auch von
Plural Subjekten bekommen noch näher
drauf inwiefern können kollektive
Personen wenn sie es überhaupt gibt
handeln und moralisch zu Rechenschaft
gezogen werden inwiefern sind sie
schützenswert weil normalerweise sagt
man eine Person zumindest eine
individuelle Person hat eine absolute
würde also wir dürfen Personen nicht
einfach töten das Leben von Personen
beenden das ist irgendwie nicht okay das
ist so mit dem Begriff der Person
verbunden meistens hat der Begriff der
Person noch eine normative Dimension
also da er steckt ein Wert drin ist was
ein wertvolles ein Regenwurm hätte ich
nicht das war gerade Intuition von
lindwater Baker wenn wir im Grunde
identisch sind mit Regenwürmern dann
haben wir kein Argument unser Leben zu
schützen und es von Regenwürmer nicht
oder müsste sagen alles Leben egal
welche Art ist schützenswert kann man
auch sagen gibt es auch diese Theorie
aber wie sieht es aus mit kollektiven
Personen wie verhalten sich kollektive
Personen zu individuellen Personen wie
Sie und ich einen sind
und jetzt kann man zwischen
verschiedenen Arten unterscheiden also
natürliche Personen
personenkollektive und kollektiv
Personen wir wollen uns vor allem hier
auf Kollektiv Person und sind hier also
erstmal gibt es natürliche Personen
individuelle Person das sind sie und ich
ja als Person die nicht mehr aus anderen
Personen zusammengesetzt sind
könnte vielleicht auch sagen die ja doch
einfach grundständig individuell sind
dann gibt es personenkollektive also das
zweite hier das sind jetzt lose
organisierte Gruppen man könnte auch von
Personen Aggregaten sprechen zum
Beispiel hätte ich jetzt die Idee dass
hier in diesem Raum ein
personenkollektiv sich befindet sie sind
ein Personen Kollektiv würde ich sagen
sie sind eine lose organisierte Gruppe
letzte Sitzung waren von Werder da da
waren vielleicht zehn mehr ja morgen
sind vielleicht wieder fünf mehr da das
heißt sie haben irgendwie eine Einheit
als Gruppe sie sind in der Gruppe ja
warum sind sie eine Gruppe weil sie ein
gemeinsames Interesse haben
ja die Vorlesung zu besuchen die Klausur
zu bestehen aber es ist nicht so
verbindlich ja also sie können auch mal
wieder rausgehen sie müssen ja nicht
permanent sein ich würde sagen sind
Personen Kollektiv wir können darüber
diskutieren gleichen ob sie vielleicht
sogar eine kollektivperson sind aber das
wäre dann schon eine starke these wir
müssen jetzt noch klären was eine
kollektivperson sind Kollektiv Personen
sagt man sind zum Beispiel juristische
Personen der von ihr hat schon was von
juristischer Person gehört studiert
jemanden von ihm sogar noch nebenher
aber sie haben schon was davon gehört
also eine juristische Person
die muss man davon unterscheiden das
sind kollektivpersonen die haben noch
eine stärkere Einheit oder Identität die
die Gruppe zusammenhält und verbindlich
auch irgendwie definiert das sind zum
Beispiel Vereine die Organe besitzen das
ist natürlich eine Metapher natürlich
hat eine
kollektivperson wenn es sich gibt keine
Organe wie wir ein Herz oder eine Lunge
oder ich weiß nicht was also Metapher
aber gar nicht trivial und sie sind
träge
kollektivpersonen juristische Personen
von Rechten Pflichten sie können auch
handeln
und sie können zum Beispiel etwas Erben
also man kann ja auch Vereinen etwas
vererben hat Tierschutzvereine werden
häufig bedacht wenn es um Erbe geht es
heißt die können etwas Erbe die können
auch klagen Vereine und Sie können auch
verklagt werden also hier spricht man
auch manche von Plural Subjekten sie als
Gruppe als vorlesungsgruppe können
nichts erben in der Gesamtheit jeder
verdient kann als einzelne Person was
Erben aber sie als Gruppe wenn ich jetzt
wenn jetzt hier irgendwie ein eher
Nachlass wäre ein Erbe und sagt das soll
jetzt an die
Gruppe der Vorlesung im Wintersemester
2022 gehen die Gruppe soll das Erben das
würde juristisch nicht gehen ja da sind
sie einfach als zusammenhalten
um mögliches Subjekt eines Erbes zu sein
anders ist es jetzt mit juristischen
Personen die noch eine Stärke Einheit
besitzen jetzt wollen wir mal ein
bisschen auf juristische Person ich bin
kein Jurist aber so viel kann man denke
ich auch aus philosophischer Sicht sagen
es gibt juristische Personen im
Privatrecht und im öffentlichen Recht
privat ist also das was nicht öffentlich
ist und was ihr kommerziell ist also zum
Beispiel Vereine wenn sie jetzt
kommerziell interessiert sind
Aktiengesellschaften zum Beispiel Tesla
und Stiftungen also Privatstiftung und
dann gibt es noch das öffentliche Recht
das finde ich jetzt sogar noch ein
bisschen spannender auch da gibt es
juristische Person Bundesländer sind
juristische Personen
Rundfunkanstalten die ARD ist eine
Person
das ZDF auch und die Universität
Konstanz ist auch eine juristische
Person während ich also ihnen nichts
vererben könnte als Gruppe könnte man
der Universität Konstanz was vererben ja
das all seinen Unterschied in der
Identität die die ist es eine Gruppe
Universität Konstanz müssen wir auch
gleich noch genauer darüber diskutieren
aber es hat eine Stärke Einheit finde
ich also ganz spannend dass man hier von
Personen spricht wir machen jetzt gleich
eine kleine Diskussion
also in der Geschichte der Philosophie
genauer gesagt in der Rechtsphilosophie
sie merken wir sind jetzt schon der
Rechtsphilosophie ein bisschen gibt es
verschiedene Auffassungen was jetzt ja
Kollektiv Person anbelangt wir haben
jetzt immer so getan als gibt es die
juristische Person gibt es de facto ja
aber auch da kann man darüber streiten
sind juristische Personen jetzt
kollektive Person oder es ist nur eine
Konvention also steckt da mehr dahinter
als nur so ein Label existieren die auf
eine andere Weise als wir sie und ich
als natürliche Person existieren jetzt
gibt es zunächst mal den sogenannten
fiktionalismus
das ist von Friedrich Karl von sarité
sie können sich schon vorstellen was
diese Theorie besagt da steht natürlich
Fiktion drin der sagt kollektivperson
sind Zitat künstliche durch bloße
Fiktion angenommene Subjekt ja also
kollektivversion gibt es eigentlich gar
nicht das ist einfach so eine Redeweise
vielleicht ist auch ein Wunsch dahinter
die haben keine wirkliche Existenz das
ist nur eine Rede von der als ob es sie
gibt so sah der gute Mann aus und jetzt
gibt es natürlich noch die Gegend
Auffassung dazu die ist die könnte man
jetzt den Realismus nennen bezüglich
Kollektiv Person das ist der Autor von
Girke und der hat gesagt Kollektiv
Personen sind Zitat ein selbstständig in
die Außenwelt
eingreifendes Subjekt also das ist
nicht nur eine Fiktion oder Bundesland
das ist ein wirklich tätiges Subjekt das
selbstständig ist da könnte man schon
fast sagen es ist autonomen er hat noch
ein paar Zitate Kollektiv Personen
stellen sie tat ein ganzes mit über
individueller Lebenseinheit da und
können nicht Zitat mit der Summe der sie
bildenden Individuen zusammenfallen also
sie kennen den Spruch das ganze ist mehr
als die Summe sagt Teile und so sagt er
ist es jetzt auch bei kollektivperson
auch wenn die kollektivperson de facto
aus ganz verschiedenen einzelnen
Personen zusammengesetzt ist können wir
sie dadurch nicht erklären das wäre der
Versuch eine Reduktion man nennt es
häufig Reduktionismus hat das kann man
auch mit der Naturwissenschaft sagen
sind wir oder ist unser Bewusstsein
erklärbar nur durch die hirnorganischen
Prozesse die da stattfinden und viele
sagen nein es geht nicht
ist eine ganz ähnliche Sache er sagt
also das ganze die kollektivversion ist
mehr als die Summe ihrer natürlichen
Person die sie auszeichnen da entsteht
was Neues wenn wir die Person
zusammenbringen natürlichen und die nach
irgendwelche haben soll ich sagen
operationsprinzipien Regeln haben
Verfassung haben dann Energie das ist
das Stichwort was man häufig bringt der
Begriffe immer ergänzt dann kommt da was
ein neues hervor was mehr ist als die
Summe der einzelnen Person noch ein
Zitat die kollektive Person ist ein
selbstständig in die
außenwelteingreifenden Subjekt das haben
wir schon gehabt und das menschliche
gemeinleben kann als ein Leben höherer
Ordnung betrachtet werden dem sich das
einzelne Leben natürliche Personen
eingliedert also das gemeinleben das
Interaktion von verschiedenen
kollektivpersonen von Staaten von
Gesellschaften und so weiter das ist
also eine höhere Form von Leben und
wissen natürlich und wo sich da einfach
unterordnen und Sie können jetzt schon
hier so ein bisschen ahnen worauf das
hinausläuft er sagt wir betrachten das
soziale Ganze gleich dem
einzelorganismus das als in Analogie zum
Organismus als ein lebendiges und
ordentlich drunter und jetzt kommt der
problematische Phrase das ganze ist ein
höheres und wertvolleres als die Summe
der Individuum und als ich das gelesen
habe habe ich gedacht oh jetzt wird es
problematisch
da steckt doch ein bisschen was
totalitäres dahinter warum soll jetzt
hier das gesamte ein Staat etwas
Wertvolleres zum Beispiel und höher das
sein als die Summe der Individuum könnte
da nicht vielleicht dann auch ein
bisschen die Problematik liegen dass am
Ende des einzelnen Individuum gar nichts
mehr zählt und nur noch das Kollektiv
was zählt also das möchte ich einfach
ein bisschen problematisieren muss man
immer schauen wie weit geht man wie weit
ist man bereit eine kollektivperson als
solche anzuerkennen und was hat das dann
verfolgen auch die Bedeutung der
individuellen Person kann man sie
dennoch auch in ihrer würde schätzen und
jetzt habe ich in zwei Positionen
vorgestellt und jetzt möchte ich sie
wieder hier zur Diskussion gleich bieten
nämlich gibt es
kollektivpersonen also fiktionalismus
sagt nein das sind nur Fiktionen also
denken Sie jetzt nicht an juristische
Person das ist eine juristische
Terminologie überlegen Sie sich mal gibt
es wirkliche
personengruppierungen die durch ihre
Regeln wirklich auch handeln können
starken Sinne oder würden Sie sagen nee
das ist eher eine Fiktion das ist eine
Rede als ob eigentlich kann man da nicht
von der Kollektiv Person sprechen ja
und jetzt möchte ich einfach
weitermachen und mal ein bisschen
konkrete darauf eingehen wie es mit
dieser Vorgeschichte der kollektiven
Person aussieht wir haben schon gesehen
es hat häufig was auch von einer
politischen Dimension wenn sie mal
dahinschauen das werden Sie erkennen ist
der Leviathan das ist von Thomas Hort
und auch da ist so ein bisschen die
Kollektiv Person angedacht also diese
Figur hier
das ist eine mächtige Figur die hat hier
ein Schwert und das ist ein anderes
Hoheitszeichen hat auch eine Krone auf
und das ist wohl dieser Leviathan und er
beschreibt den ist es eine Person für
deren Handlung sich eine große Menge
durch gegenseitigen Vertrag zum Urheber
gemacht hat zudem Zweck dass es ihre
aller Stärke und Mittel wie es im
vorteilhaft erscheint für ihren Frieden
und ihre gemeinsamen Verteidigung
gebraucht also nähere Menschen tun sich
zusammen eben von ihrer Macht ab und
dadurch entsteht eine so könnte man
sagen wirklich Kollektiv Person der
Leviathan der wird auch häufig ein
bisschen ja sehr mächtig dargestellt
bei bei Thomas ist es schon vor
vorgeformt könnte man sagen denn durch
diese Ermächtigung die von Dir von jedem
einzelnen Gemeinwesen enthält steht ihm
so viel verdienen Macht und Stärke zur
Verfügung dass er durch den Schrecken
vor ihr befähigt wird den Willen aller
auf Frieden daheim und auf gegenseitige
Hilfe gegen ihre auswärtigen Feinde zu
lenken also es geht hier um Delegation
Übertragung von individueller Markt
Vermögen Kompetenzen an einen ja Start
und eine Personal gedachte staatliches
Struktur und hier geht es vor allem um
Macht wir können macht delegieren das
machen wir auch immer wieder in
politischen zusammen delegieren wir auch
machen an Politikerinnen und Politiker
an die Exekutive und so weiter also wir
geben etwas von uns ab aber mit dem Sinn
uns dadurch selbst zu schützen und
dadurch selbst auch wieder was zu
erlangen das ist jetzt also Thomas Hobbs
und in anderen kennen Sie auch das ist
der Russe haben Sie sicherlich auch
schon so ohne unterscheidet zwischen dem
gemeinwille dem der volonté general und
dem bloßen Wille aller der Volon
sagt es gibt oft ein beträchtlichen
Unterschied zwischen dem gesamtwillen da
können Sie sich auch in Analogie zur
kollektivperson ist bloße Person
Kollektiv vorstellen also die einzelnen
die noch nicht organisiert sind der
volontier du tust und dem Gemeinden
general dieser sieht nur auf das
gemeininteresse also dieser der
gemeinwille sieht nur auf das gemeint
dass sie auf die Einheit jene der
volatile plus also die der gesamtwille
auf das Privatinteresse und ist nichts
anderes als die Summe von Sonderfällen
also Ihre individuellen Willen
zusammengefasst das ist bloß der
gesamtwelle aber nimmt von eben diesen
das mehr oder wenig weg dass ich
gegenseitig aufhebt so bleibt als Summe
der Unterschiede der Gemeinde also so
wie wir unterscheiden können zwischen
bloßen Personen kollektiven also lose
verbünden und kollektivperson so kann
man auch schon ganz ähnlich auf der
Ebene des Willens nach Rousseau
unterscheiden zwischen dem bloßen
gemeinwille das ist einfach alle
willensinteressen angesucht
zusammengesammelt und dem
Gemeinwillen wo eine höhere Form von
Wille nämlich sichtbar wird der
eigentliche Wille einer vernünftigen
Gesellschaft
ja und hier unten sagt er den der
Antrieb des reinen Begehrens ist da
dabei und der Gehorsam gegen das selbst
gegebene Gesetz ist Freiheit also das
ist der Witz wir geben uns selbst ein
Gesetz in der Gemeinschaft durch den am
Gemeinwillen und darin besteht auch
unsere Freiheit alles gibt verschiedene
kollektive
Organisationsprinzipien wie wir auch
unseren Willen gemeinsam bilden können
so dass wir am Ende nicht irgendwie
schlechten Kompromiss haben auch jetzt
machen wir halt irgendwie was gemeinsam
das ist halt irgendwie ein befriedigt
aber irgendwie doch nicht jeden
überzeugt oder ob wir irgendwie den
reinen Willen der hinter unseren allen
Interessen steckt ob wir den gemeinsam
bilden können also bei Thomas Hobbs und
bei Rosso finden wir schon so ein
bisschen was von kollektiver Personen
angedacht
und jetzt gehen wir mal ein bisschen
weiter jetzt haben wir nämlich eine
neuere Philosophie die Margaret Gilbert
geboren 1942 und die hat jetzt einen
interessanten Begriff ins Spiel gebracht
nämlich den Begriff des Joint commitment
und das Plural subject und sie hat drei
Bücher geschrieben die möchte ich Ihnen
auch nicht vorenthalten einmal on social
effects als über soziale Tatsachen es
gibt auch soziale Tatsachen und noch
zwei weitere das wichtigste Buch ist das
erste ich stelle da auch mal ein
bisschen was rein wenn Sie es mal
interessiert auf Ilias es gibt soziale
Tatsachen und jetzt kann man sich fragen
wie entstehen denn solche
kollektivpersonen oder Plural subjects
für den sie jetzt sprechen
sie sagt human beans create joint
commitments together and there by
constitute Plural Soundtracks also es
geht darum dass man joint commitments
gemeinsame Verpflichtungen
und durch diese gemeinsam Verpflichtung
denen sich alle Individuen auch
unterordnen weil sie ja selbst denken
sie zurück an Rousseau selbst das auch
am Ende entschieden haben entsteht dann
etwas Gemeinsames people for a plural
subtric in my sense when they are
jointly committed to doing something
else body
innere sense of doo also wenn sie
gemeinsam wieder committed sind
verpflichtet sind etwas als ein Körper
Körper ist jetzt vielleicht für den
Metapher als eine Einheit zu tun und das
ist ein weiterer Sinn von Pool
also wieder joint commitment gemeinsame
Verpflichtung die ist sogar die
intelligente Basis also die lässt du
überhaupt das kollektive Handeln
verständlich werden es geht um die
commitments
und jetzt sagt sie noch was
joint commitment is a holistic one in
the following sense it cannot be Analyst
in Trans of a Thunder Agregate of
personal commitments das ist wieder die
Frage wie hängen jetzt Plural subjects
wir können mal vielleicht sagen
Kollektiv Person und individuelle
Personen zusammen und sie sagt jetzt ein
Joint commitment also ein gemeinsamer
Verpflichtungen auf die wir uns geeinigt
haben die ist holistisch holistisch
heißt die ist die betrifft das ganze
und die können mir nicht erklären indem
wir sie als Summe oder bloßes
zusammenzählen Aggregat zusammenbringen
der individuellen
persönlichen individuellen ja
commitments Verpflichtungen ansehen ja
also wieder dasselbe Thema wie vorhin
kollektivpersonen oder personenkollektiv
können wir das ganze reduzieren auf die
einzelnen Interessen oder steckt da mehr
dahinter ist das ganze doch mehr als die
Summe seiner Teile sie sagt es ist mehr
als die Summe seiner Teile das ganze als
ein Joint commitment ein gemeinsam eine
gemeinsame Verpflichtung ist mehr als
die Verpflichtungen der einzelnen
Individuen in einem solchen Kollektiv ja
wie Handeln jetzt Kollektiv Personen das
müssen wir uns natürlich jetzt auch noch
fragen wie handelt die denn genau also
individuelle Person schließen sich
zusammen durch Verpflichtungen und haben
gemeinsame Ziele und Absichten auf die
sie sich zum Beispiel sprachlich
geeinigt haben also wird diskutieren
miteinander machen der Abstimmung
miteinander wir wählen etwas das sind
Prozesse durch die sich solche
kollektivpersonen auch konstituieren und
auch handeln können jetzt ist natürlich
das interessante wir haben darüber schon
gesprochen kollektivpersonen können sie
erweitern die können wachsen und Sie
können auch sich verkleinern Sie können
schrumpfen ja Beispiel vereint es gibt
unzählige Vereine nehmen wir mal hier
ein Beispiel den Anglerverein
TV
Konstanze Vermutung dass es sowas geben
könnte ist wenn jemand im Anglerverein
ich habe mir fast gedacht also ich
glaube Anglervereine haben es heutzutage
sehr schwer zu überleben jetzt spreche
ich von Anglerverein wie von Personen
oder von Tierarten also es gibt Vereine
die haben einfach mal mehr Mitglieder
und vor allem die haben weniger ja
trotzdem existiert der Verein immer noch
seit 1904 ja hat harte und bessere
Zeiten durchgemacht das heißt das haben
wir schon besprochen die Identität eines
Vereins ist unabhängig davon wie viele
Mitglieder sie hat aber zwei Personen
sollte ein Verein mindestens haben eines
wissen sonst kann er gar nicht gegründet
werden ja aber da kann es verschiedene
Endungen gibt und jetzt ist noch ein
wichtiger Punkt Personen Kollektiv
Person existieren so lange wie die
gemeinsam Verpflichtung bestehen bzw
ihre Mitglieder danach sich richten all
die Verpflichtung müssen auch
eingehalten werden und jedes einzelne
Mitglied muss ich ihn verpflichten ja
sonst funktioniert das ganz sicher
und jetzt kommt ein paar ganz wichtige
Begriffe die sich merken sollten es gibt
jetzt kollektives beabsichtigen
kollektive Intentionalität
kollektives verpflichten und und das
wird uns zur nächsten Sitzung
kollektives Handeln wir müssen jetzt
natürlich noch genau bestimmen was
Handeln ist machen wir nächsten Sitzung
aber alles was für individuelle Person
geht individuelle Personen können was
beabsichtigen Sie können sich auf etwas
richten das ist Intentionalität also
intender die Intention auf etwas
hinrichten sie können sich verpflichten
und Sie können auch handeln das gilt
sagen viele auch für kollektivpersonen
die könnte es genauso machen nur sind
dazu ganz andere Mechanismen nötig als
für individuelle Person warum weil man
hier immer die Gesamtheit hinter sich
bringen muss ist der Witz ja stellen sie
mal vor die Vorsitzende des
anglervereins
der Universität von Konstanz gegründet
im Jahr 1904 die wohnsitzende macht
einfach was sie will ja sie
siedelt neuartige Fische im konstanter
Bodensee an wenn wir exotische Fische
und die fressen alle anderen Fische auf
ja und sie hat sich über die anderen
Mitglieder hinweggesetzt ja dann
funktioniert der Verein nicht mehr wenn
Sie das täte müsste sie Rechenschaft
abgeben für ihre Taten und müsste dann
auch was befürchten dass zumindest nicht
mehr gewählt wird vielleicht gibt es
noch mehrere Konsequenzen das heißt es
funktioniert wirklich nur wenn alle mit
an einem Strang ziehen und sich nach
Regeln richten und das ist anders als
eben bei individuellen Personen
individuelle Personen können vielleicht
behandelt werden Kollektiv Person wenn
es sich gibt wenn sie existieren die
können nicht so leicht handeln da muss
immer alles geregelt werden da muss da
gibt es auch sowas wie Willkür wenn
willkürlich überhaupt nicht entdeckt
gibt es eigentlich nur sehr schwer warum
weil das alles intersubjektive Prozesse
sind die gemeinsam formiert werden
müssen wir kommen gleich noch auf die
Diskussion
und ich hatte schon gesagt man muss
unterscheiden zwischen kollektivperson
und personenkollektiven denken Sie mal
auch an den Unterschied zwischen
Staatenbund und Bundesstaat ja ein
Bundesstaat und wir Deutschland ja
darstellt ist hat eine viel stärkere
Einheit als ein bloßer Staatenbund ja
beim Starten Bund da stehen die
individuellen Staaten sind beim
Bundesstaat steht der Staat im Zentrum
der immer noch aus verschiedenen
Bündnissen eben bestehen kann
wir müssen jetzt weitergehen und noch
ein bisschen schauen um auf das
Verhältnis zwischen individuellen
Personen und kollektivpersonen und ich
möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen stellen die
dann auch zur Abschlussdiskussion führen
also erstmal ist es gar nicht unbedingt
klar was eine Kollektiv Person ist
nehmen wir mal joint commitment nehmen
wir mal Idealfall joint commitment das
heißt verschiedene Personen sind sich
einfach einig in dem was sie tun also
nicht dass da manche Leute wie im Staat
vielleicht ist gar nicht tun wollen das
war ein gutes Beispiel sind immer mal
den Idealfall joint commitment wir haben
fünf Personen und die verpflichten sich
auf etwas das ist natürlich keine
juristische Person unbedingt könnte sein
es ist auch eine juristische Person muss
auch nicht sein ja also wir haben jetzt
hier eine joint commitment
total eng gefühlt besitzen
kollektivpersonen eine absolute so wie
es individuelle Person tun
ist es moralisch verwerflich die
Existenz einer
kollektivpersonen Ende zu bereiten sind
kollektivpersonen schützenswert
haben kollektivpersonen Recht und
Pflichten wir haben schon ein bisschen
gesehen bei den juristischen Personen
Grundgesetz Artikel 19 Absatz 3 die
Grundrechte gelten auch für inländische
juristische Personen soweit sie ihren
Wesen darauf diese anwendbar sind ja das
ist auch ziemlich vage formuliert
inwiefern sie anwendbar sind ein
Grundrechte müssen wir schauen was sind
Grundrechte das wissen Sie sicherlich
auch was Grundrechte sind Grundgesetz
Artikel 5 zum Beispiel Absatz 3 Kunst
und Wissenschaft Forschung und Lehre
sind frei die Freiheit der Lehre
entbindet nicht von der Treue zu
Verfassung also ein Grundrecht ist die
forschungskunstfreiheit
Wissenschaftsfreiheit das heißt die
Universität könnte man sagen als
juristische Person die hat auch
Grundrechte also hier die Universität
Konstanz da ist Forschung Lehre frei
also ich darf in meiner Lehre machen was
ich will sofern ich hier verfassungstreu
bin also wer nicht hier keine
Verfassungs irgendwelchen Symbole hier
an der Wand in präsentiere und es geht
jetzt sowohl wenn ich es recht
verstanden habe für die Universität als
auch eben für die individuellen Person
da ist es ganz ähnlich ja dann werden
gewisse Grundrechte garantiert auch für
kollektivpersonen
ja inwiefern können jetzt das
interessiert mich persönlich auch
besonders können kollektivpersonen für
handeln wir haben gesehen handeln von
kollektivpersonen ist ziemlich träge und
komplexer Prozess zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden wie handelt überhaupt
jetzt eine kollektivperson nehmen was
Beispiel der juristischen Person eine
juristische Person handelt durch ihre
Organe also jetzt nicht Lunge Leber Herz
oder so sondern ein Organ einer
juristischen Person ist zum Beispiel der
Vorstand oder die Mitgliedsversammlung
dadurch handelt eine juristische Person
wir haben hier noch was im Bürgerlichen
Gesetzbuch der Verein ist für den
Schaden verantwortlich in der Vorstand
ein Mitglied des Vorstands oder ein
anderer verfassungsmäßig berufene
Vertreter durch einen Ausführung der ihm
zustehenden Verrichtung begangene zum
Schadensersatz verpflichtete Handlung
einen dritten zufügt
also der Verein ist für den Schaden
verantwortlich natürlich jetzt vor allem
finanziell ja wenn hier irgendwie eine
vorgesetzte Person etwas tut dann haftet
der Verein als Ganzes
finanziell das ist schon mal interessant
dann gibt es aber noch andere Straftaten
die begangen werden können
dann spricht man vom sogenannten
organwald also für diejenigen natürliche
Person die die Organe letztendlich
repräsentieren also hier hat die
juristische Rechtsprechung ganz
interessante Fälle vor gesehen für die
Haftung innerhalb von den juristischen
Personen entscheidend ist hier die sind
hier die Organe also eine
kollektivperson oder genau genommen
jetzt ein juristische Person die
organisiert sich durch verschiedene
Funktionen und die Funktion sind auch
nicht willkürlich sondern Funktionen
werden häufig durch Wahl auch bestimmt
wir wählen einen Vorstand im Verein so
also inwiefern können die jetzt zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden Kollektiv
Person nehmen wir mal hier eine
verbrecherische Organisation die NSDAP
oder umweltverschmutzende Unternehmen
Aktiengesellschaften
im Privatrecht die auch eigentlich ein
Verbrechen begehen können wenn sie eben
verschmutzen willentlich wenn irgendwie
ein großes Chemieunternehmen ganz
bewusst alle Abwässer hier in ein Fluss
lässt und alle Fische sterben und
Menschen werden krank dadurch dass sie
die Abwässer trinken ja wie sieht es
damit aus ja kann man sich jetzt mal
wirklich überlegen wer trägt jetzt die
Verantwortung konkret wenn ja
kollektivpersonen wenn man sagen kann
dieses Unternehmen hat
die Abwässer in den Rhein gelassen
die zu tragen dafür und darüber würde
ich jetzt gerne mit Ihnen noch zum
Schluss diskutieren also wer ist dafür
verantwortlich sind es die Funktionäre
je nach Rolle die sie gespielt haben hat
also die Vorsitzende Person
die meiste Strafe dann zu befürchten
denken sie zurück an Diktaturen eine
Nationalsozialismus wie war es damals ja
das würde ich jetzt gerne noch mit Ihnen
diskutieren zum Schluss